please remember that you don't need four
months about lost in history
how many times did they die yeah that's
right
ask your sister yeah I saw that
oh yes killaz then out this could be
scary
this time you say that's Ashley okay
yeah she's alright she's been Emily
there's a hand yeah so okay originally I
thought that was victim that was not
Victor that was some kind of saw that
was some kind of creepy wolf bear thing
that was even book he was reading before
so I still think that Victor is bad to
help them in 2005 I don't think it's
like that but then it seems that
Bethenny I got killed by which one
follow pop she was a pretty hectic right
now I should be we should be stand right
now but I'm not stairs I was never sure
that Oh
did you jump in like but yeah I trusted
the triangle
it's just really running in the side
with no show has he seen something's
gonna jump out or bra closing its with
that is it Oh
so [ __ ] but Oh would you do such awful
hey I'm so every fall I know you like
that's [ __ ] close I really miss that
this should be drag tracks Jimmy or John
not sure it could die here anything else
might have you might disagree help him
what's the matter with you mind yeah I
need some help we don't even know you
this is what Mattel Jinsu so these are
often babies complete strangers
intelligent indecisive month yeah I'm
gonna be really safe everything yeah
because I said we don't like I think
that you know the killer's China stuff
is actually happening now we could be
risking people's lives at the point
that's not at all
I'm safe keep it out sceneries darling
boy Oh always great to see you
somebody shut the door what is give us a
call yeah this is the part where it gets
tricky
call me very slowly just I'm just gonna
casually stroll guys seem to exist
I don't know this place is for nothing
is this is so much stuff just before I
don't know I feel like it can't be
because the way you want wait there is a
runway okay yeah
oh [ __ ] oh my god what went wrong no
well that's a first step
she's dead oh [ __ ] no I mean what we did
it flashed back to the jumping was that
the problem do we do it too safe because
I wouldn't feel like there like at
choices were obvious when someone was
going to die so people in the comics
have been telling me to explore more and
find more stuff that's [ __ ] up [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I really miss that
there's a person up there that I just
shot did you get it yeah so if we do
have the choice of not doing which is a
bit stiff so maybe it's about us and
exploring but we don't really have time
to say for quick I wanna say okay but
yeah because we need to finish this game
in a certain time we can't just [ __ ]
those try to submit these buttons that
are having a crisis before oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] I really know whatever die big
buttons on the controller Oh a trial run
again time so I press them just as they
blow up and I don't know my father
just twice like show it suck [ __ ] [ __ ]
how is he not day to fit he should
definitely be day no I don't want him to
die go safe and we already just can kill
Jess and I don't know how he did it
[ __ ] there was like a weird flashback
thing
please let that be a book that was
really stressful and you should
definitely be dead use a really small
room anytime so I think he's going to
try to find a police car
yeah I'm pretty sure I shop
and his food is done online
he's the other person there and just
like a spunky Joel ripped off so
this person would say that so that that
was the person to earn a wage there was
and it was a person at the top but the
jaw had been ripped off by the thing
with the claws that's why again I feel
it's a little bit like him we sort of
issue it's a really messed up and in
doing that it could be just a mess up
looking person or two separate things
because why would it not why would that
person not like killing like as well
right ah I'm so mad that just died
yeah well she wasn't still a huge rock
so we don't want anyone to die lately
well excepting now I think that if if
possible would avoid letting anyone die
like instantly I wouldn't blame them all
yeah absolutely
I'm not scared right now this is turning
upside for you but I know that I should
be scared but I'm not and something's
wrong now you didn't say that
how do you keep racing over jumps tears
that one [ __ ] up eyes I know mine is
on me
[ __ ] I'm lucky
did he see that I don't know I don't
know if my sword and I feel like APU how
to say any more comment on it because
it's [ __ ] up
well I'm one he's not gay because I
would never listen
low visibility and actually the wasp and
very cold dinner that was like a mess
toys all with buses to it not only
useful and why are we going like is that
really what we want to do